>> Sally: Hey Dude, look who's here.
It's my friend Izzy the iGEMer.
She just stopped by for a visit.
>> Dude: Whoa!
I've never met a real iGEMer before!
>> Izzy: Hey Dude, great to meet you.
>> Sally: I need to split some
cells in the tissue culture room,
but I thought that you and Izzy could chat.
Maybe she could tell you
a bit about her project?
>> Dude: Awesome!
>> Dude: So what was your iGEM project?
>> Izzy: Well we tried to engineer
a bacterial arsenic detector.
>> Dude: A what?
>> Izzy: A bacterial cell that could
tell us when arsenic is present in water.
>> Izzy: See arsenic contamination
in drinking water is a big problem
for people living in Bangladesh and West Bengal.
And since there's no easy way to
know if arsenic is in the water,
people there have been drinking
contaminated water and getting sick .
So we wanted to engineer a biological system
that people can use to test
their water for arsenic.
>> Dude: I had no idea this was such a problem!
What a great project to work on.
How does your system work?
00:01:03,686 --> 00:01:03,636
>> Izzy: Well our goal or the system
specification as engineers call it was
to have people mix a little of their drinking
water, with a culture of bacteria and know
that there's arsenic contamination
if the liquid changes color.
>> Dude: Awesome!.
But how did you get a bacteria to do that?
I'm still trying to figure how to
make my bacterial balloon work!
>> Izzy: Well like all engineers,
we used abstraction to help us.
Let's take a look.
>> Izzy: We knew we needed to build a
system that could take as input arsenic
and produce as output a change in the color.
>> Izzy: So first, we compiled
our system into devices.
We needed one device that could
detect arsenic and produce a signal.
We called this our arsenic sensor and
gave it a part number, BBA J33201.
And we needed a second device that could
produce a color when it got the signal
from our arsenic sensor that
there's arsenic around.
We called this color reporter BBA J33202.
>> Dude: I don't get it.
Why are you using two devices?
Wouldn't it be way easier to make
just one: arsenic in and color out?
>> Izzy: Well you could do it that way.
But then the only thing that the
device could be used for is to report
on arsenic contamination with color.
By splitting the system into two
devices, a sensor and a reporter,
we hope future iGEM teams can use
one or the other for new projects.
>> Dude: How?
>> Sally: Well a team could connect the arsenic
sensor device to a different reporter device
that say, produces light instead of color.
Or a team could build a new system that
detects say, mercury contamination,
and then produces a color as a response.
>> Izzy: Yep, we designed our system
so that people can more easily
reuse and build on our work!
>> Dude: Oh I get it!
Maybe I could connect your arsenic sensor
device to my balloon-making device!
>> Izzy: Exactly!
>> Dude: But shouldn't I know a little more
about how the arsenic sensor works before I
just hook it up to by balloon making device?
Sally got kinda upset last time I didn't'
stop the balloons from growing and growing...
>> Izzy: That's why we entered both devices
into the Registry of Standard Biological Parts.
We also documented our project online
at the iGEM wiki to make it easier
for others to build upon our work.
>> Sally: The goal is that eventually,
for each device in the Registry,
there will be a datasheet available that
summarizes all the relevant information
about that device so that you know how to use it
in a higher level system
like the arsenic detector.
>> Dude: You mean just like this old datasheet
I found for this a 7404 hex inverter chip?
>> Sally: Yep.
But I'm afraid there's still a lot
of work to do before all the parts
and devices in the Registry have datasheets.
>> Dude: Great!
Lots of work to do.
Let's get started!